Chur am 12. Februar 2020.
Ein historisches Ereignis beginnt.
Morgen.
Es ist so weit.
- (Mann) Ja, schon?
Jawohl.
Guten Morgen.
Morgen.
Jetzt gilt es ernst. Ich glaube,
alle spüren eine gewisse Spannung.
Funktioniert alles,
was wir geplant haben?
Geht es auf?
Wie ist es in der neuen Anstalt?
Insgesamt 35 verurteilte Verbrecher
werden verlegt:
Mörder, Vergewaltiger,
Dealer, Diebe, Betrüger.
Ich habe keine Angst.
Das wäre auch das falsche Gefühl.
Ich bin sehr zuversichtlich, dass
klappt, was wir vorbereitet haben.
Mit dem Umzug vom Churer Sennhof
ins neue Gefängnis Cazis Tignez
beginnt für die Schweiz
ein neues Kapitel im Strafvollzug.
Wenige Monate vor dem Umzug
besuchen wir zum ersten Mal
das Gefängnis
am Rande der Altstadt von Chur.
Seit 200 Jahren
sitzen Straftäter hinter
diesen mittelalterlichen Mauern.
Der Tag beginnt um 6 Uhr.
Danach gibt's Frühstück.
(Mann) Morgen.
- Morgen.
Guten Appetit.
(Mann) Danke sehr.
- Bitte. Morgen.
Um 7 Uhr geht's zur Arbeit.
Jeden Mittwoch begrüsst Schwester
Veronika die Insassen im Hof.
Alles wie immer, und doch ...
Pronto?
Omo? Ja. Ja.
Daniel Solenthaler arbeitet
seit über 16 Jahren im Sennhof.
Man wusste,
dass mal etwas Neues kommen würde,
aber es wurde immer konkreter,
und jetzt sind wir im Sommer 2019.
Und jetzt wird es noch konkreter.
Einige gehen nächsten Monat schon
ins Neue, um es kennenzulernen.
Trotzdem muss es hier
bis zum letzten Tag weiterlaufen.
Wir können nicht einfach aufhören
und mit dem Umzug anfangen.
Wir müssen
den Betrieb aufrechterhalten,
und das bis zur letzten Sekunde.
Bis dann muss es laufen.
Kaum sind die Häftlinge
bei der Arbeit,
überprüft Barbara Kohler,
ob auch wirklich keiner mehr
in der Zelle ist.
Die Arbeit hier
ist sicher nicht so angenehm.
Es ist nicht mehr zeitgemäss
und zu eng.
Auf der sozialen Ebene
ist es aber familiärer.
Ich kenne jeden Insassen mit Namen,
weiss, was er getan hat,
welche Eigenheiten er hat.
Sie wissen auch ...
Das ist zwar eigentlich weniger gut,
aber sie kennen uns auch
entsprechend gut.
Vom Sozialen her
ist es eher familiär,
und man kann ihnen besser
auf den Weg helfen.
Das ist so eine ...
Wie soll ich das sagen?
... eine Eigenschaft.
Wir tragen das Omo rein,
aber es funktioniert nicht anders.
Würden wir
die ganze Packung reinstellen,
wäre sie nach einem Tag weg.
Sie glauben immer noch,
je mehr man reintut,
desto sauberer wird die Wäsche.
Wer will Omo?
So.
In diesen dunklen Gängen
ist es schon nicht mehr zeitgemäss.
Wir sind hier auch
täglich eingeschlossen,
und wenn man
durch den Sennhof geht ...
Das sind z.T. enge Gänge.
Links und rechts sind Wände,
und du
hast kaum Fluchtmöglichkeiten.
Der Zahn auch.
- Das muss der Arzt anschauen.
Das kann ich nicht selbst bestimmen.
- Okay.
Okay? Gut.
Barbara Kohler
ist ausgebildete Polizistin.
Sie hat sich
wegen der Aussicht auf den Umzug
in die neue Vollzugsanstalt
Cazis Tignez
für die Arbeit im Gefängnis
entschieden.
Die Sicherheit
ist hier sicher nicht mehr gegeben.
Z.B. die Aussenmauer - eine Mauer,
und dann kommt die Zivilbevölkerung.
Das ist nicht zeigemäss.
So ist das.
Ein Sprung, und sie sind weg.
Nein, das ist übertrieben,
aber ... Ja.
Der Sennhof ist über die Jahre immer
wieder umgebaut und erweitert worden.
Eng ist er geblieben.
* Kurzes Warnsignal *
Um 9.15 Uhr ist Pause.
Im Innenhof:
nichts Grünes, kein einziger Baum.
In der Schreinerei
arbeiten die Häftlinge am liebsten.
Angeleitet werden sie seit 20 Jahren
von Ignaz Flepp.
Aber das hier ist ja tipptopp.
Sie arbeiten gerne hier.
Besonders jetzt,
da wir die Möbel für die Zellen
des neuen Gefängnisses machen.
Das ist
eine besondere Herausforderung.
Und sie machen es gerne.
Nein, das ist gut. Ja, ja.
Es ist schon eine besondere Arbeit,
aber letztlich sind das Menschen
wie du und ich.
Man muss sie
auf derselben Ebene sehen.
Wir hatten hier auch schon Juristen,
Anwälte und alles Mögliche,
die jahrelang Spiesse machten,
und es funktionierte tipptopp.
Aber es gibt schon auch andere -
etwa solche, die getötet haben.
Man muss aber jeden
als Person respektieren
und nicht nur das Delikt sehen.
* Lautes Sirren einer Säge *
Schwester Veronika Ebnöther
ist Seelsorgerin im Sennhof.
Regelmässig sucht sie
das Gespräch mit den Häftlingen.
Manche erzählen
von Problemen hier drin.
Z.B. wenn sie irgendeinen Konflikt
mit dem Personal
oder untereinander haben.
Wenn sie irgendwas
bedrückt oder belastet.
Dann gibt's Probleme mit der Familie
oder der Freundin draussen.
Oder Geldsorgen.
Es sind auch Dinge wie
allein in der Zelle zu sein,
also wenn sie sich allein fühlen
oder Platzangst haben.
Und dann gibt's solche,
die eine Frage im Glauben haben
oder das Ganze im Licht
eines Glaubens sehen wollen.
Dort kann ich auch
Hilfestellung leisten.
Ich sage ihnen auch, dass sie
mit mir über alles reden können.
Es muss nicht über Gott sein.
Um Haute Cuisine
geht's im Knast nicht,
aber für Insassen aus einem Dutzend
verschiedener Nationen zu kochen,
hat es in sich.
Eine Speise geht immer.
Es ist interessant:
Walliser Käseschnitte
mögen sie unheimlich gerne.
Toast, eine reife Tomate,
guter Raclettekäse,
drauf etwas Paprika streuen.
Das mögen sie unheimlich gerne.
Es ist der geschmolzene Käse.
Voilà.
Das Essen und das Fernsehprogramm
sind wichtig.
Und später dann mal die Freiheit.
Aber da können wir nichts machen.
Das entscheiden zum Glück andere.
* Signalglocke *
Um 11.35 Uhr ist Mittagspause.
Guten Appetit.
- (Mann) Danke sehr.
Der ganze Tag ist durchgetaktet.
Jede Handlung der Häftlinge
wird kontrolliert.
Unsere Aufgabe
ist die Resozialisierung.
Man gibt ihnen so gut wie möglich
alles auf den Weg mit.
Wenn er rauskommt und sich freut
und nicht ein Jahr später
wieder hier ist,
ist das für uns auch ein gutes Omen.
Oder man sieht sie mal in der Stadt,
und sie rufen von Weitem -
das ist auch schön.
Chefin des Hauses
ist seit acht Jahren Ines Follador.
Ihr Job war immer anspruchsvoll,
doch gegenwärtig
leistet sie doppelte Arbeit.
Es ist nicht zu wenig, oder?
Dann ist ja gut.
Schmeckt's euch?
- (Alle) Ja, super.
Wir kommen
mit 34 Leuten vom Sennhof,
und am Ende
haben wir etwa 130 Mitarbeiter.
Dass sich da jeder
wieder im Team findet
und sich auch wohlfühlt, damit er
seinen Job gut erledigen kann -
ich glaube, das ist
eine grosse Herausforderung.
Das andere ist, die
gewohnten Abläufe aus dem Sennhof
auf die grosse Anstalt
zu übertragen.
Da muss jedes Zahnrad
ins nächste greifen.
Das Gefängnis als Zukunft und Chance.
Mit solchen Slogans
wirbt die Direktorin für Personal.
Es gibt auch sehr viele sehr
bewegende Momente hinter den Mauern,
die man miterleben darf.
Das ist für uns wirklich bewegend.
Wir haben also
einen spannenden Auftrag.
Ja, das kann man sagen.
Wir suchen jemanden,
der sich für den Job
und unsere Aufgabe interessiert,
der gerne mit anderen arbeitet -
seien das Kollegen, Kolleginnen
oder natürlich Menschen,
die sich eher
am Rand der Gesellschaft befinden,
die manchmal auch
ein Delikt begangen haben,
das nicht immer
einfach nachvollziehbar ist.
Trotzdem muss man arbeiten und
ein positives Menschenbild haben.
Das ist das Wichtigste.
Die Gefängnisdirektorin
sucht Personen,
die mind. 30 Jahre alt sind und eine
abgeschlossene Berufslehre haben.
... Artikel 75 im Strafgesetzbuch.
Dort können Sie lesen,
dass der Strafvollzug
das Sozialverhalten der Gefangenen
zu fördern hat -
insbesondere die Fähigkeit,
danach straffrei leben zu können.
Das ist unsere Hauptaufgabe
und unser Alltag.
Sehr vielfältig,
sehr abwechslungsreich.
Eigentlich
ist kein Tag wie der andere.
Wer sich darauf einlässt,
bekommt einen schönen Job.
Zum Schluss präsentiert sie
eine Animation
des zukünftigen Arbeitsortes.
Das neue Gefängnis in Cazis Tignez
ist sicherheitstechnisch
auf allerneuestem Stand.
Ines Follador
wird von der Bündner Regierung
auch zur Direktorin
des neuen Gefängnisses gewählt.
Nicht ohne Stolz
führt sie uns durch die Anlage,
noch bevor diese in Betrieb ist.
Das ist ziemlich weitläufig.
- Das Gebäude ist 220 m lang.
Da macht man über den Tag
einige Kilometer.
Alles zu Fuss?
- Ja.
Aber ich gehe gern zu Fuss.
Hier sind wir
in der medizinischen Abteilung.
Hier haben wir Arztzimmer,
die Büros der Pflege,
hier sehen wir die Physiotherapie -
sie wird noch eingerichtet.
Wir haben viele Behandlungsräume
direkt in der Anstalt,
damit wir nicht
mit den Insassen rausgehen müssen.
Das wäre personalintensiv,
weil wir sie mit mind.
zwei Mitarbeitern begleiten müssen.
Und andererseits
können wir dabei die Sicherheit
nicht mehr
ganz so gut gewährleisten.
Hier haben wir
ein medizinisches Bad.
Wenn man aus
medizinischen Gründen baden muss,
können wir das hier machen.
Hier gehen wir jetzt zum Zahnarzt.
Hier sehen Sie den Zahnarztstuhl.
Auch das ist,
damit wir nicht zu einem
externen Zahnarzt gehen müssen.
Wir haben eine ganze Einrichtung,
damit wir möglichst viel
im Haus machen können.
Hier haben wir noch
ein kleines Labor.
Damit können wir alles
im Haus machen.
Hier ist der Speise-
und Aufenthaltsraum der Insassen.
25 wohnen hier miteinander -
eine Zwangsgemeinschaft.
Sie haben hier eine Art WG.
Hier sehen Sie den Aufenthaltsraum,
wo sie abends während
des Zellenfreigangs spielen können.
Und hier sehen wir den Zellengang.
Die 25 Zellen
sind alle gleich eingerichtet.
Wir betreten gleich mal Zelle 20.
Ich öffne die Tür.
Die Zelle ist 12,1 m2 gross.
Wir haben sie mit Möbeln vom Sennhof
und vom Realta ausgestattet -
wir durften sie also in den
eigenen Schreinereien herstellen.
Wir sehen hier ein Waschbecken,
ein WC, ein Bett,
einen Tisch, auf dem PC
und Fernseher stehen werden,
und v.a. haben wir
ein sehr grosses Fenster,
das die Insassen
selbst öffnen können,
damit sie doch einen gewissen Hauch
von Freiheit verspüren können.
Das ist ja fast wie ein Hotelzimmer.
- Das könnte es sein.
Manche sagen vielleicht auch,
es sei ein Hotel.
Aber wenn man bedenkt,
dass alles vorgeschrieben wird,
die Zellentür
um 19.45 Uhr geschlossen
und erst um 7.15 Uhr
wieder geöffnet wird ...
Sie öffnet sich in der Zeit nicht,
man muss hier bleiben,
und das vielleicht
über fünf oder zehn Jahre.
Und wenn man draussen ist,
wird alles andere auch vorgegeben.
Ich glaube,
die Freiheit ist das Grösste,
was man einer Person entziehen kann.
Das neue Gefängnis
hat 119 Mio. Fr. gekostet.
Es hat Platz für 152 Häftlinge
aus der ganzen Region Ostschweiz.
Die meisten
kommen aus dem Kanton Zürich.
Selbst wenn sie hier rauskommen
würden, wäre es schwierig.
Genau. Hier sehen Sie einen Teil
unserer Sicherheitsanlagen.
Zunächst haben wir hier
den Ordnungszaun.
Dahinter einen nicht besteigbaren
Sicherheitszaun mit Detektoren.
Darüber ist noch NATO-Draht.
Dahinter ist die 7 m hohe Mauer.
Sie ist 1 km lang
und führt um die ganze Anlage.
Hinter der Mauer
ist ein weiterer Ordnungszaun.
So haben wir die vorgeschriebenen
Sicherheitsabstände.
Das hatten wir im Sennhof
alles nicht.
Im Sennhof führt Barbara Kohler
weiterhin Kontrollen durch.
In regelmässigen Stichproben
sucht sie die Zellen nach Drogen,
Alkohol, Handys oder Waffen ab.
Es gibt schon
raffiniert gemachte Verstecke.
Sie haben die ganze Nacht Zeit,
um etwas vor uns zu verstecken.
Da sind der Fantasie
keine Grenzen gesetzt.
Es ist für uns natürlich schwierig,
zu eruieren,
ob da etwas versteckt ist.
Das sieht gut aus.
Ich verstaue das sachte hier.
Ich lese von den Insassen
nichts durch.
Ich schaue nur,
ob irgendwo Substanzen
oder gefährliche Gegenstände
drin sind.
Damit sieht man hinter die Mauer.
Das ist natürlich immer
ein gutes Versteck.
Das ist die Schraube.
Ich schaue hier auch rein.
Das ist auch ein gutes Versteck.
Aber hier ist alles gut.
Das Wichtigste in diesem Job:
Man muss authentisch sein
und Menschen mögen.
In meinen Augen
ist das das wichtigste Kriterium.
Und man muss auch flexibel sein.
Ja, flexibel.
Und man muss in schwierigen Situa-
tionen einen kühlen Kopf bewahren.
Mussten Sie das auch schon?
- Ja.
Man muss fast jeden Tag
schwierige Situationen meistern.
Das macht es ja auch spannend.
Das macht es interessant.
Hier haben wir Gegenstände,
die wir im Laufe
der letzten Jahre gefunden haben:
Telefone, Stichwaffen -
sie verstecken auch Medikamente.
Wenn Sie z.B. hier mal schauen:
Das befindet sich
in einer normalen Bürste.
Aber auch bei einer solchen Bürste
findet man ideale Verstecke.
Da kann man Tabletten,
Drogen usw. verstecken.
Wenn das wieder geschlossen ist,
sieht man von aussen nicht,
dass da etwas drin ist.
Das ist ein Beispiel.
- Was ist denn das?
Das gehörte einem Insassen,
der ein fotografisches
Gedächtnis hatte.
Es reichte, wenn er den Schlüssel
des Aufsehers gesehen hatte,
damit er sich alles merken konnte.
Z.B., wie
der Schlüsselbart gemacht war
oder wie die Löcher
angeordnet waren.
An dieser Geschichte
ist faszinierend,
dass sie voll funktionstüchtig
waren, als wir sie fanden.
Das ist ...
Eben, sie sind uns oft
einen Schritt voraus.
Sie haben oft Ideen, auf die wir
noch gar nicht gekommen sind.
Was ist das hier unten?
Hier sind Briefe.
Ja, das ist ...
... die weniger schöne Seite.
Briefe, die wir konfiszierten.
Die Briefe zeigten, warum er hier
eine Strafe absitzen musste.
Es war besser,
dass er hier und nicht draussen war.
War das ein Mörder?
- Ja.
Ein Frauenmörder?
- Es ging damals eher gegen Kinder.
Es ist nicht schön,
wenn man selbst solche Dinge sieht.
Für mich waren es damals erst
einfach normale Briefe.
Als ich dann aber selbst
Kinder zu Hause hatte,
und dann v.a. auch noch Mädchen,
ging mir das natürlich
viel tiefer unter die Haut.
Unsere Aufgabe hier drin
ist ja letzten Endes,
dafür zu sorgen, dass solche Dinge
eben nicht weitergehen
und dass wir den Insassen letztlich
auf eine andere Bahn bringen können.
Die Resozialisierung.
* Durchdringender Warnton *
Jeder Häftling muss sich mit
seinem Verbrechen auseinandersetzen.
Das geschieht
in Form von Therapien und Gesprächen
mit Schwester Veronika,
mit Psychiatern, Psychologen
oder dem Sozialdienst.
Angst habe ich nie.
Ich weiss, Gott hält seine Hand
auch unter den tiefsten Abgrund.
Sie erzählen ja z.T. auch
von ihrem Delikt.
Es erschreckt mich ...
Es gibt Momente,
in denen es befremdlich ist,
aber es erschreckt mich nie.
Ich spreche immer wieder
vom Verzeihen.
Es ist ein grosser Brocken,
jemandem zu verzeihen
oder um Verzeihung zu bitten.
Aber ich will ihnen zeigen, dass es
auch ihnen mehr Frieden gibt,
wenn sie das können.
Letzten Endes sind Anklage, Rache
und Hass eine Selbstzerfleischung.
Alle zwei Wochen
versammelt Schwester Veronika
die Insassen zum gemeinsamen Gebet.
Ich möchte diesen Menschen zeigen,
dass es Gott gibt
und dass er sie liebt -
egal, was sie getan haben.
Ich investiere in diese Menschen
mit dem, was ich habe.
Und dann hoffe ich einfach,
und ich hoffe auch,
dass Gott dort weitermacht,
wo ich den Anstoss gebe.
Was ist diese Ressource,
die Sie haben?
Ich hoffe, es ist eine grosse Liebe.
Das ist das Wichtigste.
Eine bedingungslose Liebe,
die ich auch
in meinem geistlichen Leben spüre.
Ich befasse mich auch damit, dass
ich von dieser Liebe erfüllt bin.
So kann ich sie weitergeben.
Es ist eine Liebe zum Menschen
und der Glaube,
dass in jedem Menschen
etwas Verschüttetes ist,
das aber unzerstörbar ist.
Vielleicht
kann ich helfen oder anregen,
dass das wieder zur Entfaltung kommt
und aufblüht.
Ich will dem Eingewiesenen
auch vermitteln,
dass er selbst daran glauben darf,
dass da etwas ist,
was niemand zerstören kann -
nicht einmal er selbst.
Eine solche Betreuung wäre in
der Vergangenheit undenkbar gewesen.
Daniel Solenthaler
zeigt uns das Gefängnismuseum.
So. Das ist eine Daumenschraube.
Das geht heutzutage
fast unter Folter.
Vielleicht hat man damit
ein Geständnis erpresst -
ich weiss nicht,
wie die das früher gemacht haben.
Oder wenn der Schmerz davon
grösser war als andere Dinge,
tat man vielleicht auch,
was die anderen wollten.
Das ist wegen der Noppen da
ziemlich schmerzhaft.
Es ist gut ...
Es ist schön, dass wir es
noch haben, v.a. für unser Museum,
aber es ist gut,
dass es nicht mehr angewendet wird.
Alte Handschellen.
Vielleicht waren die Menschen
früher kleiner -
das müssen sie gewesen sein,
denn die hier sind ziemlich klein.
Oder vielleicht
waren sie für Frauen.
Das können wir nicht mehr eruieren.
Hier haben wir noch Fussfesseln.
Das hatten wir auch noch.
Ach, noch die Kettenstrafe.
Die Kettenstrafe wurde am Anfang
hier drin noch vollzogen.
Hier wurden wirklich noch
Menschen angekettet,
und das nicht nur für ein paar Tage
oder Wochen, sondern über Jahre.
Das war dann ein Urteil
von 20 Jahren Kettenstrafe oder so.
Im 20. Jh.
wurde die Kettenstrafe abgeschafft,
aber die Haft war weiterhin auf
absolute Unterwerfung ausgerichtet.
Diese Bilder
aus dem Zuchthaus Regensdorf zeigen:
Die Häftlinge
trugen Nummern statt Namen.
Reihenfolge und Abstand beim Hofgang
waren streng vorgegeben.
Sprechen war verboten.
So was hatten damals die Aufseher.
Hier haben wir eine Feder.
Die wurde eingesetzt ...
- ... zum Schlagen.
Ja, und die taten ziemlich weh.
Das ist heute nicht mehr erlaubt.
Und sonst hatte man früher
solche Gummiknüppel.
Hartgummi.
Das tut auch ziemlich weh.
So etwas verwenden wir heute
sicher auch nicht mehr.
Das gilt auch für dieses Teil.
Ein Elektroschocker.
Ich habe ihn nicht reparieren
können - ich habe es versucht.
Die sind heutzutage
auch nicht mehr angesagt.
Relikte von früher.
Noch zu Beginn des 21. Jh.
haftete dem Sennhof der Ruf an,
der härteste Knast der Schweiz
zu sein.
Die Häftlinge durften ihre Zelle
nur zur Arbeit verlassen.
Sie verbrachten den Grossteil
ihrer Strafe in Isolation.
(Mann) Monoton, stereotyp,
immer das Gleiche.
Auf Befehl pissen,
auf Befehl schlafen.
Einfach die Tristesse,
die hier herrscht.
Die ist schon etwas unangenehm.
(Mann)
Ich komme mir vor wie weggestellt.
D.h., so ein Problem
wird in eine Kiste gepackt.
Nach zwei, zweieinhalb Jahren
wird die Kiste geöffnet,
und das Problem ist wieder da.
Es wird zwar immer
von Resozialisierung gesprochen,
aber das ist ein Witz.
Okay, dann gute Nacht.
Das Regime der Isolation
wurde erst 2007 abgeschafft.
Jetzt, da der Sennhof
seinem Ende zugeht,
scheint es,
als komme so etwas wie Wehmut auf.
Besonders da es
gegen Weihnachten geht.
Einige Häftlinge
basteln mit der Gefängnislehrerin
die Weihnachtsdekoration.
Wie ist der Alltag hier drin?
(Mann) Ich habe es mir
schlimmer vorgestellt.
Wenn man mit den richtigen Leuten
zusammen ist,
wenn man sich die richtigen
aussucht, passt es eigentlich.
(Mann) Wir sind zwei Schweizer.
Die anderen sind alle Ausländer.
Ja, es gibt nicht viele Schweizer.
- Im Moment.
Im ganzen Vollzug.
- Ja.
Wie viele sind's? Vier Schweizer?
Die anderen sind alle Ausländer.
Ja, glaube ich auch.
Doch, wunderschön. - Den Stern
von Bethlehem haben wir auch.
Genau. Eine Spitze aus Glas und
ein paar Geschenke gibt's auch noch.
Das ist die letzte Adventsfeier,
die wir mit den Insassen begehen.
Beim einen oder anderen -
bei mir sicher -
wird Wehmut aufkommen,
denn dass alle dabei sind,
wird nicht mehr vorkommen.
# Ah, ah. Sometimes in our lives ...
Er ist lauter.
Filmen dürfen wir nicht?
- Nein.
Das wäre ein Störfaktor.
Das Fest findet in einem intimen,
geschlossenen Rahmen statt.
Ich glaube, bei manchen
kommen da Emotionen hoch.
Darum wollen wir unter uns bleiben.
# (Chor) Silent night.
# Holy night.
Auch an Weihnachten ist
die Überwachung unverändert streng,
aber für kurze Zeit
werden die Häftlinge zu Gästen.
Sie werden bedient, und aus der Küche
kommt ein Menü vom Feinsten.
Feine Nudeln mit Knoblauchcrevetten,
dazu ein Kalbscarrébraten
mit Kartoffelgratin,
Sauce béarnaise,
drei verschiedenen Gemüsesorten
und als Dessert Parfait glacé.
Das ist fast wie im Grandhotel.
# Sleep in heavenly peace.
Im neuen Jahr
gehen die Vorbereitungen
für die Inbetriebnahme des
neuen Gefängnisses in die Endrunde.
Morgen.
Daniel Solenthaler muss auf dem Weg
zu seinem Arbeitsplatz
15 Türen öffnen.
Insgesamt
zählt das Gefängnis über 600 Türen.
Morgen.
- Morgen, Dani.
Die eigenen Schlüssel und das Handy
kommen in ein Schliessfach.
Mit dem Gefängnishandy
kann er nicht nur telefonieren,
sondern per Knopfdruck
auch Alarm auslösen.
Die Ausrüstung
besteht aus einer Uniformhose,
einem Poloshirt oder einem Hemd,
und dann je nach Wetter
kommt vielleicht eine Regenjacke
oder eine Softshell-Jacke dazu.
Waffen?
- Das hat mit ... Waffen?
Waffen, das ist immer ...
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Wir haben einen Pfefferspray,
eine Taschenlampe und Handschuhe.
Oft sage ich neuen Mitarbeitern:
"Nehmt noch eine Waffe mit:
den Respekt."
Herzlich willkommen. Eine derart
grosse Runde hatten wir noch nie.
In den Schulungen
für das neue Personal
geht es v.a. um das Erlernen des
richtigen Umgangs mit Straftätern.
Der Hauptteil ist Halden, ein sog.
Vorzeigegefängnis in Norwegen,
wo man sehr
auf die Resozialisierung achtet.
Sie haben auch viele Angebote
für die Insassen.
Der Schlüsselbegriff
im norwegischen Vollzugssystem
heisst dynamische Sicherheit.
Es geht um Respekt, Vertrauen
und das schwierige Verhältnis
von Nähe und Distanz
zwischen den Vollzugsbeamten
und den Insassen.
Unsere Aufgaben fallen unter den
Aspekt der dynamischen Sicherheit.
Wir wollen mal schauen,
was für uns auch zwingend wichtig
und was eher wünschenswert ist.
Wir fangen mit dem Film an.
(Mann im Film) Dynamische Sicherheit
ist keine Spitzentechnologie.
Alles dreht sich
um gute Kommunikation,
die auf Respekt aufbaut.
Wir sehen den Insassen
nicht als Kriminellen,
sondern als Menschen,
der eine Straftat begangen hat.
Daraus entsteht
ein Dialog voller Respekt.
Den brauchen wir
bei der dynamischen Sicherheit.
Wo stösst das System der
dynamischen Sicherheit an Grenzen?
Wenn der Mitarbeiter den Insassen
zu nahe an sich ranlässt.
Das ist nicht gut.
Man muss
ein gesundes Mittelmass finden.
(Ignaz Flepp) Wenn man nicht spürt,
dass der Insasse mehr rausholt,
als wir geben wollen.
Das kann vielleicht auch
ein Nachteil sein.
Und mit den Insassen spielen?
- Ich denke schon.
Bei einem Spiel kann man sicher mal
ein Thema anschneiden,
für das man im Alltag
vielleicht keine Zeit hat.
Dort sind Auserwählte dabei,
bei denen man sagen kann:
"Wir können sie
in dieses System eingliedern
und auch so mit ihnen arbeiten."
Aber die haben sicher auch welche,
mit denen ich nicht
Fussball spielen würde,
weil ich nach 10 Min.
flach am Spielfeldrand liegen würde.
Selbstverständlich
gehört zur Ausbildung
auch das regelmässige Üben
der Selbstverteidigung.
So macht er nichts mehr.
Jetzt können wir hier ziehen ...
... und Griff.
Dann können wir zu unserer
Sicherheit die Handschellen anlegen.
Beim Anlegen der Handschellen
darauf achten,
dass die Arme
so weit unten sind wie möglich.
Dann müsst ihr damit
nicht viel hantieren
und es gibt keine Druckstellen.
Bei unseren Hilfsmitteln
achten wir immer darauf,
dass wir sie so einsetzen können,
dass der Insasse
möglichst geringe Schmerzen hat.
Bei der Handschellentechnik
hat Herr Muoth gerade gezeigt,
dass man die Arme hinten
und möglichst tief halten muss,
damit man die Handschellen
nicht über die Knöchel legen muss.
Das tut weniger weh.
Halt, oder ich spraye!
- Stopp, oder ich spraye!
* Stöhnen *
(Muoth) Den anderen Arm nach hinten.
- Ganz ruhig.
Ich lege Ihnen Handschellen an,
dann schauen wir mal.
Geht's? Den Kopf auf die Seite
drehen und ruhig atmen.
Ganz langsam. Okay.
Man kann sie schon anpacken,
aber das ist nicht unser Auftrag.
Der ist laut Artikel 75
die Resozialisierung.
Ich glaube, jeder dieser Insassen
könnte mein oder Ihr Nachbar sein.
Wenn einer Hass auf eine Institution
oder ein staatliches System
verspürt,
will ich den
wohl nicht als Nachbarn haben.
Und ich will ihm nicht
im Coop begegnen,
wenn er gerade sehr aufgebracht ist
und vielleicht ein Messer dabei hat.
Wir sind Teil dieses Systems,
das aber auch diese Aufgabe hat,
die wir mit allen Konsequenzen
und Grenzen unterstützen -
denn die gibt's selbstverständlich.
Über die müssen wir
auch nicht verhandeln.
Wenn wir das vermitteln, können wir
jemandem so den Weg zeigen.
Ich finde, das ist unser Auftrag -
nicht die Erniedrigung.
Die Strafe ist der Freiheitsentzug.
Und diesen vollziehen wir auch.
Einen Tag vor dem grossen Umzug
werden die Insassen im Sennhof
in den kleinen Spazierhof gesperrt.
Das Personal räumt die Zellen.
Jedem Insassen steht eine Kiste
für seine persönlichen Sachen zu.
Jetzt geht es zu Ende.
- Das sind die letzten Überbleibsel.
Es war eine lange Zeit.
Was soll ich sagen?
Der Sennhof
ist mir ans Herz gewachsen.
Das können viele
vielleicht nicht verstehen,
aber ich habe
die letzten 16 Jahre hier verbracht.
Ich war täglich hier
und habe hier gearbeitet.
Es ist nicht einfach vorbei und ...
... aus den Augen, aus dem Sinn.
Ich werde den Sennhof
noch lange in Gedanken behalten.
Aber man muss nach vorne schauen
und das Alte zurückstellen.
Ich freue mich extrem
auf das Neue im Tignez.
* Klappern
eines schweren Schlüsselbunds *
21 Uhr abends.
Zum letzten Mal werden im Sennhof
Medikamente verteilt.
Guten Abend.
(Mann) Waren Sie vorhin
unten im Garten?
Ja.
- Ich habe gepfiffen.
Ich hab's gehört.
- Schlimm?
Nein. Bitte sehr.
- Es war halt ein Spass.
Ja. Gute Nachtruhe.
- Gute Nacht.
Dann ist es so weit:
Am Morgen des 12. Februar 2020 fährt
der Zellenbus im Gefängnishof ein.
Morgen.
- Guten Morgen.
Es ist so weit.
- Ja, schon?
Jawohl.
Guten Morgen.
Morgen.
- Guten Morgen.
* Leises Stimmengewirr *
Hier rein.
Aus Sicherheitsgründen
werden die Häftlinge
in kleinen Sechsergruppen
ins neue Gefängnis transportiert.
Bei einem Gefangenentransport
besteht höchste Fluchtgefahr.
Sind Sie angespannt?
Nicht wirklich, aber man geht
gewisse Szenarien im Kopf durch -
was passieren könnte
und wie man dann reagieren muss.
Man macht sich schon Gedanken.
Es kann Meutereien geben,
es kann Befreiungsaktionen geben.
Damit müssen wir immer rechnen.
Man muss hier
immer wieder reflektieren.
Gerade mal 24 km beträgt die Distanz
vom alten zum neuen Gefängnis,
und doch ist es eine Reise
in eine andere Welt.
Auch bei der Ankunft
läuft alles wie geplant.
Grüezi.
Es folgen die üblichen Formalitäten.
Danke.
Zehn Jahre nach dem Entscheid,
ein neues Gefängnis zu bauen,
werden die ersten Häftlinge
in ihre Zellen geführt.
Hier haben wir den Zellenruf.
Zellenruf. Hier ist das Licht.
Das ist dieses Licht
über dem Waschbecken.
Das sind die Rollläden.
* Stimmengewirr *
Als Erstes werden die Häftlinge in
die wichtigste Neuerung eingeführt:
Sie müssen in Zukunft ihre
persönlichen Einkäufe oder Wünsche
über das gefängniseigene Netz
tätigen.
Hier können Sie auswählen.
Im Sennhof lief das
über den persönlichen Austausch
mit dem Personal.
Neu ist auch, dass Häftlinge
und Betreuer gemeinsam essen.
Wir haben jetzt einen
ganz anderen Bezug zu den Insassen,
weil sie zuerst hierherkommen
und Essen fassen,
dann kommen wir, fassen auch und
setzen uns zu ihnen an die Tische.
Das tut gut. Also, mir tut es gut.
Da kommt wieder die ...
Wir sind zur Betreuung hier.
Das erfüllt einen.
Zumindest erfüllt es mich,
wenn ich mit ihnen etwas tun kann,
statt wie früher einfach
den Schlüssel zu zücken
und abzuschliessen.
Diese Zeiten sind längst vorbei.
Jetzt steht die Betreuung
im Vordergrund.
Der Hofgang führt hier
durch den sog. Checkpoint,
einen Detektor, der alles anzeigt,
was die Sicherheit bedrohen könnte.
* Stimmengewirr *
... im Vergleich zu Deutschland.
Wenn die in München
das sehen würden,
würden sie den ganzen Tag heulen.
Die würden umfallen,
wenn sie das sehen könnten.
Ich hatte
überhaupt keine Vorstellung.
Im Vergleich zum alten Sennhof
ist das tipptopp.
Ich bin vor 20-30 Min. angekommen.
Bis jetzt ist es super.
* Lautes Stimmengewirr *
Sie suchen sich jetzt Plätze.
Aber ... abwarten.
Sie sind noch skeptisch.
Ja, es ist noch etwas frisch,
da ist es nicht so ...
Aber man sieht schon:
Sie probieren die Geräte aus.
Das wird schon gut gehen.
Bislang sind sie zufrieden.
Mir gefällt es hier sehr gut.
Es ist schön,
und alle haben gute Laune.
Das könnte schon einen Einfluss
auf die Stimmung haben.
Ja.
Es sollte von beiden Seiten
ein schönes Gefühl sein,
dass sie angekommen sind. Ja.
Die Turnstange ist begehrt.
- Ja.
So ist es richtig.
Derweil verlässt
der letzte Zellenbus den Sennhof.
Bis später.
- Bis später.
Ich glaube, wir sind alle stolz.
Nach 202 Jahren Sennhof umzuziehen,
ist sicher auch
mit Wehmut verbunden.
Aber oben nehmen wir
die neue Anstalt in Betrieb.
Das bedeutet für mich auch immer:
beseelen und mit Leben füllen.
Und zwar mit Leben,
das einem ab und zu Freude bereitet,
obwohl manche glauben,
das wäre eine Umgebung,
die einem keine Freude macht.
Trotzdem war der Sennhof beseelt.
Jetzt müssen wir das
in die neue Anstalt übernehmen.
Am späten Nachmittag
wird die letzte Zelle geräumt.
Der Sennhof ist Geschichte.
Vier Monate nach dem Umzug
besuchen wir erneut
das Gefängnis von Cazis Tignez.
(Mann) Keine Kamera, bitte.
Keine Kamera, bitte.
Man sieht Sie nicht.
Auf Sie ist keine Kamera gerichtet.
Die Bedingungen
sind für uns dieselben geblieben:
Wir drehen nur unter Aufsicht,
wir zeigen keine Gesichter
der Häftlinge
und wir sprechen nicht
über ihre Straftaten.
Barbara Kohlers Arbeitsplatz
ist jetzt in der Sicherheitszentrale.
Wir hatten einen guten Start.
Wir wussten, wie das ablaufen würde,
aber es ist für uns auch neu,
denn es sind jeden Tag
Neueintritte gekommen.
Das hat sich sukzessive aufgebaut.
Wir hatten immer mehr Leute.
Und wir waren die vielen Leute
nicht gewohnt.
Plötzlich hat man 100 Personen
vor sich und denkt:
"Hoppla,
jetzt sind wir langsam voll."
Ich kenne viele Insassen nicht.
Dass es nicht mehr so familiär ist,
macht es für uns
z.T. auch schwieriger.
Jede Ecke in Cazis Tignez
ist erfasst.
In der gesamten Anlage sind mehr als
500 Überwachungskameras installiert.
Den Anforderungen des
modernen Strafvollzugs entsprechend,
gibt es Räume für Therapien,
Sitzungen und Schulungen.
(Frau) Ich bin Angela Müller.
Ich bin 20 Jahre alt.
Ich bin nicht verheiratet,
sondern ledig und habe keine Kinder.
Mein Hobby ist Lesen.
Wer will anfangen?
- (Mann) Ich.
Mein Name ist Andrea Meier.
(Mann) Andrea ist ein Frauenname.
- Egal.
Egal, egal.
- Er kann auch eine Frau spielen.
Ich komme Nordirak.
Aus Nordirak.
- Aus Nordirak.
Ich bin ledig.
* Unverständlicher Einwurf *
- Pst.
Ist das alles?
- Ja, denke ich.
Gut.
Auch der neue Gefängnisalltag
folgt einem
immer gleichen, strengen Regime.
In den hellen
und übersichtliche Werkstätten
erledigen die Häftlinge
Auftragsarbeiten externer Kunden.
Das ist okay.
Dann können Sie hier weitermachen.
Gut, bis nachher.
Sie erhalten einen Lohn
von zwischen 15 und 35 Fr. pro Tag.
In der sog. Kreativwerkstätte
stellen sie Geschenkartikel her.
* Leises Stimmengewirr *
Wie lange arbeiten sie daran?
Am Grossen zusammen drei Wochen.
E i piccoli?
I piccoli, due giorni.
- Zwei Tage.
Due persone.
- Ja.
Das zu falten und zusammenzustecken,
ist wirklich sehr aufwendig.
Manchmal denke ich wirklich,
die meditieren hier.
Hier herrscht auch
eine wunderbare Stimmung.
Sie sind sehr hilfsbereit.
Ich denke schon,
dass das etwas ausmacht, ja.
Der Fuss ist hinten. Stopp, hinten.
So? Drücken?
- Da hinten.
Fühlen Sie mal, da ist ein Hebel.
Das ist der Fuss.
Ah, okay.
- Genau.
Stopp, stopp.
Der Fuss muss runter.
- Aha.
Runtersetzen und dann Gas geben.
Aber mit den Schuhen ist das schwer.
- Ach, da passiert nichts.
Nichts?
- Nein, nein.
Sie ist nicht so schnell.
Ah ...
- Nicht?
Doch, das ist gut.
Jetzt noch einmal zurück -
mit dem Knopf, ja.
Nein, Sie müssen den Knopf
gedrückt halten. - Ach so.
Jetzt geht's von allein.
Jetzt weiss ich nicht,
wo der andere Faden ist.
Hat das überhaupt genäht?
Ja. Also ... Ah, nein.
- Nein.
Ach, Mist.
- Mist.
Wirklich. Oje.
Gut, also machen wir das noch mal.
Sich auf eine Arbeit
zu konzentrieren,
diese exakt auszuführen
und die Vorgaben des Werkmeisters
zu befolgen,
ist ein wichtiger Teil
der Resozialisierung.
Wir probieren das mal aus.
Das ist gut. Tipptopp.
Wir merken schon, dass Interesse
und auch Freude aufkommen.
Diese Freude kommt von ihnen.
Dann freut es mich auch,
etwas vom Beruf zu zeigen.
was er mitnehmen kann.
Das kann ihm niemand wegnehmen
und wird ihm immer bleiben.
Eine Ausbildung, eine Lehre hat man,
und damit kann man etwas aufbauen.
Da sind wir in der kurzen Zeit
schon recht weit gekommen.
Das ist auch für
die Resozialisierung gedacht.
Ja, ja.
Es ist auch von Vorteil,
wenn man sich allein behelfen kann,
wenn zu Hause was kaputt ist.
Dann gehe ich in ein Geschäft
und miete mir die Maschine,
wenn ich sie nicht habe, repariere
das selbst und gebe sie zurück.
Das ist ... Ja.
Im Endeffekt geht's ums Sparen.
Haben ist besser als brauchen.
Gut. Ich habe Pause.
Danke für das Gespräch.
Bis nach der Pause.
Wenn man Insassen aus
dem Sennhof fragt, sagen einige:
"Viel heller,
viel besser, viel mehr Platz."
Auch diejenigen, die lange
im Sennhof gearbeitet haben,
sagen, dass sie es sich
kaum noch vorstellen können.
Ich habe den Sennhof zwar immer
als charmante Institution bezeichnet
und bleibe auch heute dabei,
aber hier ist es so hell,
dass man gar nicht das Gefühl hat,
in einem Gefängnis zu sein.
Unsere Mitarbeiter
sind noch nicht alle gewohnt,
mit Insassen umzugehen
und was Justizvollzug bedeutet,
und der Insassenbestand
ist sehr schnell gewachsen.
Unter diesen Umständen
ist es eine sehr ruhige Anstalt.
Zum einen ist es sicher die
sehr gute Arbeit der Mitarbeitenden,
aber das Gebäude
unterstützt uns dabei.
Die Gänge sind breit, man kann sich
ausweichen - Corona hin oder her -,
man hat Luft, es ist hell,
die Insassen
können die Fenster weit öffnen ...
Ich behaupte,
das Gebäude unterstützt uns
in unserer alltäglichen Arbeit.
(Schwester Veronika) Vorletzte Woche
habe ich zum ersten Mal erlebt,
dass alle 100 Mann
aus dem Normalvollzug
gemeinsam auf dem Platz waren.
Da merkte ich,
dass ich anders auftreten muss.
Jetzt muss ich wieder zeigen,
dass ich in gewissem Sinne die
Leitkuhfunktion wieder übernehme,
die sie mir auch einfach
aufoktroyieren.
Wenn ich sicher auftrete
und mich von der Stimmung auf dem
Platz nicht einschüchtern lasse,
können sie mir
wieder mehr vertrauen.
Dann vertrauen sie mir Sachen an,
weil sie merken,
dass ich das aushalten
und mittragen kann.
Oder dass ich etwas vermittle
Früher, im Sennhof, durften wir
am Wochenende für 90 Min. rausgehen.
Hier ... ist nach 1 Std. Schluss.
Eine halbe Stunde?
- 1 Std., dann ist Schluss.
Das sind Annehmlichkeiten, an die
man sich im Sennhof gewöhnt hat.
Man hatte das,
und hier wird man beschnitten.
Im Sennhof
konnte man auch Bücher bestellen,
um seine eigene Weiterbildung
voranzubringen.
Man bestellte die Bücher
natürlich auf eigene Kosten,
aber hier geht das gar nicht mehr.
Das sind nur zwei Beispiele.
Es gibt noch viele andere,
aber dafür reicht die Zeit nicht.
(Mann) Im Sennhof war es familiärer.
Man war bei allen näher dran.
Der Nachteil war dafür, dass man
fast zu nah aufeinandersass.
Da gab es Reibereien.
In diesem grösseren Laden
kommt man besser aneinander vorbei
und kann einander aus dem Weg gehen.
Hier muss man Geduld lernen.
Wenn man hier keine Geduld hat,
hat man es sehr schwer.
Die Arbeit ist angenehmer.
Man kann auch mal laufen
und die Gedanken,
die man nach einem Gespräch hat,
haben etwas mehr Platz,
weil es weitere Wege sind
als im Sennhof.
Dort war man sehr eingeengt.
Andererseits ist schade, dass
das Leben hier digitalisierter ist.
Da sind wir Seelsorger
nicht so sehr dabei.
Darum kriegen wir nicht alles mit -
auch nicht alles,
was wir wissen müssten.
Es hat Vor- und Nachteile.
Aber man arbeitet mit dem,
was man hat,
und die Hauptsache haben wir:
die direkte Begegnung
mit dem Insassen
unter vier Augen
und mit Schweigepflicht.
Das ist das Wichtigste.
Daniel Solenthaler richtet die
neu geschaffene Altersabteilung ein -
wegen der Corona-Pandemie
ein halbes Jahr verspätet.
Hier werden betagte Straftäter leben,
darunter auch Verwahrte,
die die Anstalt nie wieder verlassen
und vermutlich hier sterben werden.
Die Philosophie hier drin ist auch,
dass man den Gefängnischarakter
etwas loswird.
D.h., wenn ich hier reinkomme ...
Klar, wir haben elektrische
Türschliesser, wir haben Kameras,
wir haben überall Überwachung usw.,
aber wenn man hier reinkommt,
soll man sich wohlfühlen.
Dann sind wir genau bei dem Punkt:
Wenn wir jemanden
mit der Aussicht haben,
dass er nicht mehr rauskommt,
in der Zeit ...
Es ist ja auch für uns gut, wenn wir
einer solche Person Freude ...
Ja, eine Freude.
Er weiss,
er kann jeden Tag etwas tun,
und der Tag geht auch anders vorbei
als wenn er immer
am Zellentisch sitzt
oder im Bett liegt,
auf den nächsten Tag wartet und,
wie man es von früher kennt,
für jeden Tag
einen Strich an die Wand malt.
Das ist es nicht.
Die Anstalt muss beseelt werden.
Hier muss Leben reinkommen.
Man muss sich wohlfühlen können.
Es wird eine Herausforderung sein,
einen Konsens zu finden,
mit dem man das Leben hier
lebenswert machen kann.
In Solenthalers Augen
beginnt das beispielsweise
allein schon
bei der Beschriftung der Zellen.
Gut lesbare Nummern, klingende Namen.
Draussen hört man von Kuscheljustiz,
aber wir vollziehen hier drin
Freiheitsentzug.
Sie müssen hier drin nicht leben
wie im Mittelalter.
Diese Zeiten sind vorbei.
Aber hier geht's ja nicht mehr
um Resozialisierung.
Aber es sind immer noch Menschen.
Ich sehe die Menschen hier bei uns
nicht als ...
Klar, ich weiss von jedem,
was er getan hat.
Es sind z.T. keine
leicht verdaulichen Sachen.
Ich sehe den Menschen.
In meinen frühen Jahren
habe ich mal einen guten Spruch ...
Nein, keinen Spruch.
Ich habe von einem älteren Aufseher
einen Hinweis bekommen.
Er fragte, ob ich die vier M kenne.
Ich wusste nicht, was er meinte.
Aber die vier M sind:
"Man muss Menschen mögen."
Hier geht es um den Menschen,
nicht um ein Material oder so.
Dazu gehört
laut der Gefängnisdirektorin,
dass Häftlinge
bei tadellosem Benehmen
Anrecht auf 3-4 Std.
privater Zweisamkeit haben.
Das ist also das Familienzimmer?
- Ja, genau.
Wir haben hier
ein Bett mit zwei Matratzen,
wir haben zwei Stühle,
wir haben einen Tisch,
wir haben ein Badezimmer mit Dusche,
und hier hinten ist eine Küche.
Wer hat Anrecht
auf ein solches Zimmer?
Eigentlich alle Insassen, aber man
muss einige Bedingungen erfüllen.
Man muss eine gewisse Zeit
bei uns gewesen sein,
damit wir den Insassen
kennenlernen können.
Man sollte
eine stabile Beziehung haben,
also entweder verheiratet sein oder
eine stabile Partnerschaft haben.
Es kann auch vorkommen, dass man
sich über Briefe kennenlernt
und das auch stabil ist.
Dann kann man beantragen,
dieses Zimmer nutzen zu dürfen.
Das ist Teil der Resozialisierung.
Wenn man rauskommt,
soll man in eine stabile Beziehung
zurückgehen können.
Das hilft auch dabei,
draussen wieder Fuss zu fassen
und im normalen Alltag
leben zu können.
Man hat seine Familie, Kinder
und kann vielleicht auch wieder
der alten Arbeit nachgehen.
Ein Häftling im Normalvollzug
kostet den Schweizer Staat
301 Fr. pro Tag,
406 Fr. im Altersvollzug.
Pam, pam, pam!
In einer Zwangsgemeinschaft
wie dem Gefängnis
sollen die Verurteilten lernen,
Konflikte friedlich auszutragen.
Es ist schon von Vorteil,
seinen privaten Schliesser zu haben.
Genau. Luxus, was?
- Ja, ja, Luxus.
Dann bis später.
- Bis später.
Auch im Gefängnis
hat alles seinen Preis,
sei es Fernsehen,
Telefonieren, Rauchen
oder etwa die Nutzung eines Computers
zum Schreiben.
Diese Seife
kriegen wir nicht gratis.
Die muss man sich organisieren.
Wir bekommen nichts gratis.
Es wird im Endeffekt
für alles bezahlt.
So, und was nach jedem Händewaschen
ganz wichtig ist:
Man nehme einen Putzlappen
und macht das wieder schön sauber,
damit es danach
auch wieder super aussieht.
Es ist eigentlich schön eingerichtet.
- Ja.
Aber es fehlen noch
ein paar Haken für Handtücher.
* Stimmengewirr, Rufe *
Das grösste Gut, was man einem
nehmen kann, ist die Freizeit.
Das spüren wir jeden Tag.
Das ist korrekt, ja.
Gibt es auch Zeiten, in denen das
besonders schwierig ist?
Bei mir sind das die Feiertage,
also Weihnachten, Ostern -
was sonst Familienanlässe sind.
Hier hat man natürlich nicht
die Menschen um sich, die man mag.
Man kann, salopp gesagt,
niemanden umarmen oder so.
Das ist sicher sehr hart zu erleben.
Kein Körperkontakt ...
- Ich nenne es Verwahrlosung.
Ich würde das so nennen.
Es geht um gute Gespräche,
um vertraute Gespräche.
Es geht nur sekundär um Berührung.
Ich denke,
damit kann man klarkommen,
aber gute Gespräche,
Vertrauen, Vertrauensmissbrauch
sind Dinge, die natürlich ...
Man lebt mit Kriminellen.
Es gibt hier keinen,
der "normal" oder unschuldig ist.
Das muss einem schon bewusst sein.
Meine Tochter wird dieses Jahr 18.
Ich werde mir eines Tages
von ihr anhören müssen,
dass ich nicht da war,
als sie mich brauchte.
Sie leidet im Endeffekt
mehr als ich.
Wenn man über Dinge wie Weihnachten,
Geburtstage usw. nachdenkt,
wird's hart.
In Serbien?
- Ja.
* Leise Popmusik:
"Underwater" von MIKA *
Die Arbeiten der Häftlinge
aus den Werkstätten werden verkauft.
Um deren Markttauglichkeit zu prüfen,
besuchen externe Ladenbetreiber
die Ateliers.
Hier haben wir versucht,
etwas nachzumachen.
Wir haben verschiedene
Papiersorten bestellt
und sind noch in der Probephase.
Die sind toll.
- Ganz cool.
Das siehst du halt hier bei mir.
Wir haben das
mit der Handsäge geschnitten.
Jetzt ist es halt nicht ganz gerade.
Nein, das ist besser
als mit der Tischfräse.
Das muss
von Hand geschnitten werden.
Sie haben wirklich gute Dinge
gemacht. Das fasziniert mich auch.
Wie die Mitarbeiterinnen hier
mitleben und Ideen haben -
diese Kreativität
finde ich wahnsinnig gut.
* Stimmengewirr *
"Inhaft geschaffen",
um noch mal zu zeigen,
dass die Insassen arbeiten müssen.
Sie können mit Stolz nach aussen
gehen und das präsentieren -
in einer guten Form,
die auch nach Wertigkeit aussieht.
Das ist auch eine Wertschätzung
gegenüber den Insassen.
Was sie produzieren, wird mit einer
Wertigkeit nach aussen getragen,
und jemand sagt: "Ich bin bereit,
dafür etwas zu bezahlen."
So können wir
zur Resozialisierung beitragen.
Da kommt einiges an Post zusammen.
Ja, da kommt vieles zusammen.
Ich teile sie in Post von Anwälten
und sonstige Briefe auf.
Die Anwaltspost
wird zwar auch geröntgt,
aber wir schauen nicht rein.
Den Rest können wir öffnen,
wenn wir einen Verdacht haben,
aber die Anwaltspost nicht.
Das macht unser Sicherheitschef
Martin Muoth.
Hier sieht man gut:
Das sind medizinische Fläschchen.
Hier sind Medikamente.
Das ist etwas Metallisches.
Das ist für Martin Muoth.
Wenn ich etwas wissen will,
schaue ich rein.
Wenn man nichts zu verbergen hat ...
Wir schauen rein.
Dann machen wir einfach
unsere Arbeit.
Egal, ob es ein Insasse
oder ein Angestellter ist?
Ja. Es kann auch was reinkommen,
von dem der Angestellte nicht weiss.
Dann kommt das
aus irgendwelchen Gründen
vielleicht auf eine andere Position,
wo die Insassen Zugriff haben.
Darum kontrollieren wir
alles rigoros.
* Rascheln *
Da hört man schon:
Das sind Heftklammern.
Das hat man
auf dem Monitor gut gesehen.
Heftklammern,
um Blätter zu fixieren.
Das sind sehr gute Verstecke.
Wenn der Insasse sagt, er müsse
etwas für seine Blätter haben,
gibt man so etwas raus und dann ...
Informationen fliessen.
Sie fliessen immer.
Sie sind uns immer
einen Schritt voraus.
Martin?
Hallo, Martin.
- Tschau.
Ich habe dir die Anwaltspost
ins Büro gelegt.
Ich bringe die Medikamente weg,
dann komme ich zurück,
und du kannst sie mir
wieder mitgeben.
Hast du etwas festgestellt?
- Nein, nichts.
Gut, danke.
- Bitte.
Hier gibt's kein Postgeheimnis.
Nein, bei uns nicht.
Es gibt besondere Post,
z.B. von Anwälten,
die wir eigentlich nicht öffnen.
Ich öffne sie
nur bei einem Verdachtsfall.
Sonst ist Anwaltspost vertraulich.
Aber wenn sie beim Röntgen
etwas feststellen,
kommt das zu mir, und ich öffne es.
Ich visiere das auch,
damit der Insasse weiss,
dass jemand die Post geöffnet hat.
Martin Muoth ist für die Sicherheit
im Gefängnis verantwortlich.
Der ehemalige Schweizergardist
und Polizeiinstruktor
ist den ganzen Tag auf Kontrolltour.
Guten Morgen. Konzentriert?
(Insasse)
Ja, die Stühle müssen gut werden.
* Sie sprechen unverständlich. *
Guten Morgen, Ignaz.
Tschau.
- Alles in Ordnung?
Ja.
Werden die Sicherheitsvorgaben
eingehalten?
Ja, da müssen wir dranbleiben.
Ansonsten müsste ich
den Betrieb schliessen.
Sicherheit geht vor.
Und mit der Arbeit?
Sehr gut. Ich brauche nur
mehr gute Schreiner.
Es liegt nicht in meiner Macht,
dir bessere zu besorgen.
Wann muss
der Sicherheitschef eingreifen?
Wenn Gerüchte umgehen und ich weiss,
wer sie verbreitet,
gehe ich der Sache auf den Grund.
Was für Gerüchte?
Es gibt allerlei Gerüchte.
Es kann auch sein,
dass ein Insasse versucht,
zwei Mitarbeiter
gegeneinander auszuspielen.
Da muss man sofort intervenieren,
denn das kann man nicht akzeptieren.
Der sensibelste Bereich
sind die Ein- und Ausgänge.
Barbara Kohler
untersucht jedes Fahrzeug minutiös.
Tor 3 bitte schliessen.
Hallo, Sven.
- Hallo.
Ist das eine Leerfahrt?
- Ja. Das Material kommt noch.
Kannst du hinten bitte noch öffnen?
Hinten.
- Mhm.
Ist gut, danke.
Gehst du den Schlüssel wechseln?
- Mhm.
Während der Kontrolle
wird der Fahrzeugschlüssel
sicherheitshalber weggesperrt.
Barbara Kohler versichert uns,
dass es nicht einmal eine Maus
schaffen würde,
unbemerkt
aus dem Gefängnis zu entkommen.
Was misst das?
Wenn einer drin wäre,
würde das die Herzfrequenz messen.
Darum sollte man jetzt
nicht rumlaufen.
Niemand darf im Auto sein,
wenn wir kontrollieren.
Wenn einer drin wäre,
würde das Gerät das anzeigen -
also die Herzfrequenz, ganz minimal.
Hier würde dann
eine Störung angezeigt.
Es ist August, als Daniel Solenthaler
die Altersabteilung
endlich eröffnen kann.
Einer der ersten Insassen ist ein
älterer Herr aus dem Normalvollzug.
Hier wird er die letzten Monate
seiner Strafe absitzen,
bevor er nach Italien
abgeschoben wird.
Jetzt haben wir auch Zeit,
alles schön einzuräumen.
Ihre Zelle ist hier unten, Nummer 4.
- Ja.
So, angekommen.
- Danke sehr.
Bitte sehr.
Herein.
Es gibt nicht viele Unterschiede.
- Jawohl.
Es ist ein wenig grösser.
- Ja.
Und vielleicht eine andere Aussicht.
Sie dürfen alles einräumen.
- Ja.
Sie können auch
das Multimediasystem ausprobieren,
ob alles funktioniert.
- Ja, ich weiss, wie's funktioniert.
Ja, das wissen Sie.
Aber probieren Sie aus,
ob alles funktioniert,
und ich komme später
noch mal vorbei.
Also, bis später.
- Danke sehr.
Danke.
Ich denke, viele der Insassen
haben noch nie gearbeitet,
deshalb sagen sie, es sei hier hart.
Für mich ist es wie in den Ferien.
Die Aufseher
sind freundlich und aufmerksam -
ganz aussergewöhnliche Leute.
Gut so, oder möchten Sie mehr?
Andere Insassen
werden die Altersabteilung
voraussichtlich bis zu ihrem Tod
nicht verlassen.
Super.
Soll ich Ihnen kurz helfen?
- Gerne, ja.
Moment. Könnten Sie den Schlauch ...
- Sicher.
Sagen Sie mir,
wenn Sie so weit sind.
Sie kennen ja unsere Devise:
Miteinander geht's einfacher.
Dieses Miteinander
ist für mich eher wieder Neuland.
Nach so langer Zeit.
- Miteinander?
Als ich reinkam,
hiess es am ersten Wochenende:
"Wir könnten einen Brunch machen."
Ich dachte,
ich wäre im falschen Hotel.
Aber tatsächlich
tischte das Personal auf,
und es gab einen schönen Brunch.
Er war auch schön hergerichtet.
Das macht schon etwas mit einem.
Es ist nicht so,
dass nichts auf einen einwirkt.
Die Wirkung kommt nach dem Brunch:
"Ja, aber hallo!
Was kommt wohl als Nächstes?"
Ja, das muss man akzeptieren,
und es ist auch schön.
Und wenn es mal einen Konflikt gibt,
weiss jeder:
"Ich kann zu
Herrn Solenthaler gehen,
und der sorgt dafür, dass der
Konflikt gemeinsam gelöst wird."
Und sonst findet man sicher
eine andere Lösung.
Wir sagen ja immer, dass es keine
Problem gibt - nur gute Lösungen.
Der Start hier ist gelungen.
Das Erstaunliche ist,
dass sehr viele Dinge
so eingetroffen sind,
wie wir sie uns vorgestellt haben.
V.a. haben wir jetzt Feedback
von den Insassen bekommen.
Wir wissen,
wie sie das Ganze aufnehmen.
Das Experiment
mit den Zellenbeschriftungen
ist vom ersten Tag an
gut angekommen -
v.a., als sie sahen,
dass rundherum auch Berge sind.
Es ist etwas anderes für jemanden,
der aus
einem anderen Gefängnis kommt,
wo alles flach
oder man in einer Stadt ist.
Die Berge regen auch
zu Diskussionen an.
Es ist mal was anderes.
Und das tut allen gut.
Ich hatte letztens einen Disput,
weil ich eine Reisallergie habe.
An dem Tag gab es Reis,
und ich fragte ...
... ob ich
etwas anderes haben könnte.
"Ja, Sie wissen ja,
Sie können das und das essen."
"Und Sie wissen ja:
Sie wollen essen, Sie müssen nicht."
Bei solchen Aussagen rutscht
einem schon die Kinnlade runter.
Das ist schon klar.
Dann muss man die Hände
in den Hosentaschen behalten,
denn so was würde man sich
in freier Natur nicht bieten lassen.
Aber hier ist man halt gezwungen,
sich so was
auf den Kopf zu sagen zu lassen.
* Stimmengewirr *
(Aufnahme) Dieser Anruf erfolgt
aus einer öffentlichen Einrichtung
und kann im Rahmen
gesetzlicher Massnahmen
mitgehört oder aufgezeichnet werden.
(Insasse) Hallo.
- (Frau) Hallo.
Hörst du mich?
- Klar und deutlich.
(Mann) Ich dachte, ich mache das so.
- (Mann) Nein, tu das nicht.
Hier wird alles mitgehört?
Nicht alles, aber stichprobenartig
müssen wir mithören, was läuft.
Das ist
ein wichtiges Instrument für uns,
gerade bei Rechtsgeschäften,
die sie untereinander tätigen.
Oder sie geben jemandem draussen
den Auftrag, Geld zu überweisen.
Das können wir mithören und
nachverfolgen, wenn es was gibt.
In der Anstalt selbst
wird auch untereinander gehandelt.
Also echte Spitzelarbeit.
Am Anfang ist es ungewohnt,
wenn man mithört.
Es sind z.T. sehr intime Gespräche
zwischen Mann und Frau
oder mit den Kindern.
Es ist schon
eine besondere Situation.
Und natürlich
können wir nicht alles abhören,
aber immer wieder
stichprobenartig reinhören.
So erfahren wir auch
die Gefühlslage des Insassen.
Wenn einer in der Wohngruppe
den Eindruck macht oder sagt,
es gehe ihm schlecht,
kann man anhand eines
Telefongesprächs nachvollziehen,
wie seine Gefühlslage ist.
Teilt er das zu Hause auch so mit
oder ist das auf der Wohngruppe
nur gespielt?
Solche Erkenntnisse
können wir gewinnen.
Je länger wir die Direktorin
durch das Gefängnis begleiten,
desto deutlicher wird,
dass im hellen,
technologisch hochmodernen Gebäude
ein strenges Regime geführt wird.
Jedes Fehlverhalten wird mit Ver-
weisen, Bussen oder Arrest bestraft.
Nichts wird vergessen.
Jeder Fehler
gefährdet den ersehnten Erlass
des letzten Drittels der Strafe.
Hier stehen wir
vor der letzten Zelle.
Wie man sieht, ist sie frei,
darum können wir reingehen.
Das ist die erste Tür.
Dann gehen wir durch die zweite
und stehen im sog. Bunker.
Ein Bunker?
- Ja.
Was ist die Idee dahinter?
Das ist eine Disziplinarmassnahme,
mit der man einen Insassen
disziplinieren kann.
Das reicht von einem
bis zu max. 14 Tagen.
Es ist aber auch
eine Sicherungsmassnahme.
Wenn jemand suizidal ist,
verlegen wir ihn hier rein
und fragen bei der Forensik
nach einer Einschätzung.
Hier drin
kann man sich nichts antun.
Es ist
sehr spartanisch eingerichtet.
Wir haben hier
ein sog. unkaputtbares Waschbecken
und ein Steh-WC.
Wir haben einen betonierten Sitz,
einen betonierten Tisch,
ein betoniertes Bett -
dazu gibt's eine Wolldecke.
Das war's dann.
Und wirkt das?
- Ja.
Es wirkt oft beruhigend.
Wenn man
auf einer 25er-Wohngruppe ist
und sich
gegen 24 andere behaupten muss -
jeder ist ja "the man" -,
kann es schon sein, dass man hier
mal auf sich zurückgeworfen ist
und dann wieder zur Ruhe kommt.
Aber man hat keinen Fernseher
und nichts.
Wenn man
erbauliche Literatur haben will -
den Koran, die Bibel oder so -
darf man das haben.
Aber meistens
lesen sie hier drin nicht.
Auch Rauchen ist verboten.
Wenn ein starker Raucher
23 Std. nicht rauchen kann,
nur während 1 Std.
auf dem Spazierhof,
kann das auch hart sein.
- Mhm.
Das Fenster
kann man auch nicht öffnen.
* Stimmengewirr *
Früher oder später
kommen die meisten wieder frei.
Die Härte ist, wenn man nach relativ
langen Jahren wieder rauskommt -
das dann irgendwo ...
... wieder anzunehmen.
Dass man da nicht
in ein tiefes Loch fällt und sagt:
"Es erdrückt mich alles,
weil alles auf einmal kommt."
Denn da muss man sich selbst
um alles kümmern.
Wenn der Alltag draussen vorneweg
schon in einigermassen
geregelten Bahnen gelaufen ist,
wird man das sicher
auch wieder hinkriegen.
Man kriegt hier noch
den Druck von oben,
dass man es sich wieder einprägt
und festigt.
Aber ...
... man hat natürlich auch
bedeutend Angst davor,
wieder nach draussen zu kommen.
Dieser Mann hat sein halbes Leben
im Gefängnis verbracht.
Wie ist das Leben hier im Tignez?
Dann kommen Sie wieder raus?
- Ja.
Sie klingen ganz zufrieden.
- (Lachend) Ja.
Das Virus oder sonst was.
Das ist das Lebenselixier.
- Natürlich.
Natürlich.
Wie viele der Insassen
wieder straffällig werden,
ist nicht genau feststellbar.
Viele von ihn werden
in ihre Herkunftsländer ausgeschafft,
wenn sie die Strafe abgesessen haben.
Das ist für den anderen.
- Ja, er hat schon ...
Ich habe es letztes Mal vergessen.
Der Wiedereinstieg ins Leben draussen
ist für jeden schwierig.
Wenn man einen Job haben möchte,
muss man sich bewerben.
Man muss dies, das und jenes sagen.
Man möchte aber nicht sagen,
es sei so und so gewesen,
sondern man sagt, man habe keinen
Bock auf Arbeit gehabt oder so.
Damit man eine Chance
auf einen guten Job hat,
um wieder
auf einen grünen Zweig zu kommen.
Wenn man sagt,
dass man im Gefängnis war,
sagt der andere: "Oh, stopp.
Wir nehmen lieber einen anderen."
Es ist einfach so.
Das ist die Realität.
Da finde ich es nicht fair,
wenn die Leute draussen sagen,
dass wir hier im Luxus leben.
Dass wir nur
Wasser und Brot kriegen sollten.
Ich habe Mühe, das nachzuvollziehen.
Aber ja.
* Signalglocke *
In 5 Min.: Zelleneinschluss.
* Stimmengewirr *
Die 130 Angestellten des Cazis Tignez
wissen nicht,
wie viele ihrer Häftlinge
es draussen schaffen werden.
An ihrem Ziel, diese Männer auf
ein Leben in Freiheit vorzubereiten,
ändert das nichts.
Gute Nacht. Schönen Abend.
- Danke.
(Mann) Zu früh, zu früh, zu früh.
Bis ich bei Ihnen bin,
ist Viertel vor.
Ja, was ist mit den anderen?
Bitte, hopp, hopp, hopp!
Es ist doch viel zu früh.
* Der Insasse lacht. *
Gute Nacht.
- Gute Nacht.
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Daniel McMinn - 2020